Welcome back to Computer Vision.
This is another lecture of mechanisms or
methods that are,
they're not sort of current
computer vision research, or
really the state of the art in Computer
Vision, but they are very important
methods that we make use of all
the time for a variety of operations.
And what we're going to talk about today
is really some binary image analysis.
There are lots of times that we produce
images that are essentially zeros and
ones.
One talks at zero is a background and
one is a foreground.
So, for example, I might be looking
in fact we talked about background
subtraction when we were doing,
detection of moving objects.
Right, and so basically the ones where
the stuff was supposed to be moving and
the zeroes were supposed
to be where it wasn't.
And in fact, there was this example that
I showed of people sitting on the steps
of the University, and we did a median
filter, and then we subtracted them off.
We did a thresholding,
then I did, I said,
we did something called morphological
operations to clean it up.
Today, we're doing
the morphological operations, and
it's often buried deep within
any functioning vision system.